hey everybody big news we may have found
out what jon snow's actual Targaryen
name is there are a couple really big
theories so I'll explain what's going on
just careful for spoilers for everything
that's happened on the show so far if
you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get everything click that
Bell to make sure you don't miss out
there's going to be so much dropping
really soon the big news now is that
Empire Magazine did a big preview for
Game of Thrones they talked to a couple
of the actors they got quotes when they
talk to Isaac Hampstead right they were
talking about brands big secret but as
they quoted in the article here it says
as we saw in the last episode of season
6 brands psychic time-traveling
greensight revealed the true nature of
John's birth heritage and his real name
and then they quote Joe Harris Targaryen
and then Isaac is quoted as saying
brands now in this precarious situation
in which it's just him and Mira and he
has all this information that could
change the entire story and it's not
just about John he knows about the
origin of the White Walkers too so
there's a whole lot to unpack here but
of course when this was posted everyone
had their own theories about what was
going on like maybe the person writing
this magazine article is just
speculating it's not like the cast would
give away a big piece of information
like that but HBO themselves gave away
John's true Targaryen heritage even
though fans that had the theory for a
long time that he was the son of Rhaegar
Targaryen and Lyanna Stark the policy of
HBO thus far has been to just say
nothing like don't comment on spoilers
don't come out and say yes you're right
no you're wrong this is what's really
going on they just leave it to the show
to reveal and then maybe sometimes in
the notes after episodes post then later
on the show runners will actually
literally say this is what we were
trying to do in this scene during season
4 when the night King was turning one of
Craster's sons into another white Walker
they even put it in a big feature ed so
taking it with a grain of salt let's say
for the sake of argument that that is
John's true name Lyanna stark whispered
everything to Ned Stark explaining the
situation explaining what Jon Snow's
true name was his heritage people
lip-read and claimed that they thought
that she was saying joe harris but again
you still have to call it a theory the
only thing we know for sure is that he
would have had a Targaryen name so
just a question of what that is agon in
jahir so the two big theories for that
very big reason people lip read they
thought that he said Joe Harris and
there's a lot of story significance in
the books and on the TV show that's a
little bit different for why his name
would be one of those two things so
let's start with the books first in the
books there was a king called maegor the
cruel he was one of the sons of Aegon
the conquerer
he had trouble conceiving a son he
marries six different wives and presided
over this faith militant uprising like
he saw happen on the show during season
six and what he did like just an example
of how terrible he was he paid out gold
dragons for the scalps of the higher
born members in silver stags for the
poor fellows which is just sort of the
peasant arm of the faith militant later
in life he even had his first wife
killed the rest of his wives all met
untimely end
one of the other six claimed
responsibility for the deaths of all of
the others he cut her heart out named
one of his female cousins his heir and
in the Seven Kingdoms over his later
years loli started turning against him
even his own family eventually they took
the sword black fire the ancestral
Targaryen Valyrian blade rode off on all
the dragons and he was abandoned in his
throne room they came and found him
later impaled by the Iron Throne
believing that he killed himself or that
somebody else who had been building the
red keep for him had come and sought
revenge you see the similarity to the
Mad King the Mad King started out
actually not being that bad of a person
but slowly succumbed to the Targaryen
madness and people started to turn
against him his family started to turn
against him everyone abandoned him and
then finally he was impaled on the Iron
Throne although it was by Jamie with his
sword that's all part of how he earned
the name maegor the cruel but he was
succeeded by someone called joe harris
de wives Rhaegar father was known as the
Mad King there was this long-standing
theory that he engineered the tourney at
Harrenhal to assemble the Lords and call
a Great Council to decide how to deposed
other and put someone better on the
throne but thanks to the machinations of
Varys who was lord of whispers to the
Mad King the Mad King came to the
tourney at Harrenhal thwarting regards
plan and obviously we know things led to
Robert's rebellion and it all went into
the [ __ ] so
the idea stands that Rhaegar was going
to have a baby with someone that he
loved Lyanna stark it would be the child
of iron fights the culmination of the
prophecy of the prince who was promised
he believed in the coming of the White
Walkers so this child Jon Snow was going
to be the culmination of a new leader
that would be able to lead them through
the long night but also literally a
leader as in sitting on the Iron Throne
the counter evidence to his true name
being Aegon is just that Aegon is a big
character in the books young Griff it as
the show tends to do they give
characters storylines to other
characters on the TV show like Gendry
kind of became book II tricks storm
Aegon in the books is another contender
for the throne but because the TV shows
winnowing plot lines down it's possible
that they would just make him Aegon it
would be a vastly different version of
the book story even though it doesn't
seem like the Iron Throne is something
that Jon Snow would ever covet the TV
show evidence for his name being Jo
Harris is just that Jo Harris the second
was the father of the Mad King now it's
different in the books like the line of
Targaryen Kings is whittled way down on
the TV show so it'd be like Rhaegar
naming his baby flea on a stark after
his grandfather just trying to backspace
delete over his father like all that
terrible stuff that happened let's get
rid of it pretend like it never went
down and start over again the whole
concept of the Jon Snow character is
that Rhaegar thought that he was the
Song of Ice and Fire very literally and
he would lead them through the long
night now as we've learned from MELAS
Andrews visions prophecies visions
things in the TV show get misinterpreted
quite a bit so I think the left turn for
the TV show is that there will be no one
person who's going to lead them through
the long night even if Jon Snow's real
name is Jo Harris or if you still want
to back the AEGON theory both solid
picks so let me know in the comments
what do you think is going on in this
magazine here this is actually something
that they print and they ship and sell
for money so it's not like they would
just let this slip by many people review
this before it goes into print it's not
just like one person sitting there
writing it and then sending it off to a
printer to be made into thousands and
thousands of copies spread all over the
world so there's just a lot of fishy
things about this so I would treat it
with a grain of salt but it does imply
that they are going to reveal Jon Snow
true name and if they do I honestly
don't think that it's going to change
much for Jon Snow he still considers
himself the son of Ned Stark above all
else so even if he learned about his
true father he would probably try to
learn a little bit more about that but
this see here from the trailer makes it
look like he's going to be in such dire
circumstances that that will be the last
thing on his mind so let me know in the
comments they revealed Jon Snow's true
heritage on the TV show how many
episodes deep do you think we'll get
before that happens because it sounds
like bran is going to make it near or
south of the wall in that first episode
so if Jon Snow doesn't make it north of
the wall till the end of the season it
sounds like they would hold off the way
they held off the Tower of joy reveal
till episode 10 last year so do not be
surprised if it's a slow burn over the
course of seven episodes but leave all
your requests for bonus videos in the
comments below there'll be more Game of
Thrones as we get closer and closer to
the series dropping as long as you have
alerts enabled then you'll totally see
the videos when I post them
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winter winter is here please private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details while
you wait for my next video you can click
here for all those behind the scenes
trailers and you can click here for all
the promo videos thank you so much for
watching as I thought thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight